And now, of course, the answer is a little bit subjective because,
since all of these problems here are NP complete,
you could basically try an NP completeness reduction from anyone of those,
but we were looking for similarity; so, bioinformatics comparing DNA sequences?
Yes, that is a lot like common subsequence especially if
those sequences have certain insertions and deletions in them.
Scheduling computer programs?
That is most often a problem related to packing.
You have a number of programs and the number of machines
and you need to match programs to machines as best as you can
that is almost the same as putting packages into containers so that they are optimally filled.
Actually, scheduling is almost an individual class of NP complete problems.
If you look at the Wikipedia page that we just looked at,
you should find a couple of problems in the section scheduling.
Are K classrooms enough? That can be stated as a coloring problem.
If you have a number of courses, and for some reasons,
these courses cannot be held in the same room,
then determining a minimum number of rooms
can be the same as determining a coloring in that network.
For this course here, we are using the red classroom,
and for this room here, we're using the blue classroom,
and for example, if you wanted to use the blue classroom for this course as well,
that doesn't work because we have a connection here.
You have to use another one here and of course another one here.
That doesn't work as well, so four classrooms.
Merging the source code of two programs have been working on,
that is a common subsequence problem because the program as will have modified certain parts,
will have deleted certain parts, possibly inserted other parts,
so we need to find out what the true programming code still have in common.
Filling vans? Yeah, that was an easy one probably.
That is a classical packing problem because you're actually using packets.
Something else always calls for the universal weapon
and that universal weapon in the case of NP completeness is 3-SAT.
Now, you have a library of one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten NP complete problems
which are a good basis for showing NP completeness.
Whenever you come across a problem where you think that it might be NP complete.